thank you
thanks Ken for having us really happy to
be talking to you I
so quick note about who we are and what
we do so we're from Arcos Arcos is a new
startup in the middle Park area we're
working we're a data analytics tool and
we're working on building a a layer of
analysis that sits on top of web apis it
lets people ask questions using search
natural language about whatever data
they have coming through web apis
and to do that we've been using a lot of
go our backing is written almost fully
in go and we've been building a lot of
infrastructure on our end in order to
make that happen that infrastructure
varies from things like on the natural
language processing side context-free
grammars and parsing tools to things on
the data handling side we're working on
building a query language that we call
parklink which we use to actually
construct database queries against these
apis we're also working on building an
orn which we're using to actually Define
all of our object models and that's how
we that's how we we participate in our
system so the top talk was originally
going to be focused entirely on how we
use SQL in this Aura but we decided that
it would be more beneficial for
everybody to do that as well as talking
about the RM in general and some of the
other tools that we've built in order to
have in order to support our web
application backup
I'll let it take it from there solid
let's get started okay so we're going to
be talking about scaling a go code base
and uh some of the things they keep in
mind when you're looking to grow a web
application
um written and go so things like type
safety uh actually let's cover our needs
first so basically we're building a web
application that we expect to be around
for a long time like a good rule of
thumb with a startup code base is to
expect code that you write to be around
for half of the lifetime of of the code
base so you write code and you're like
all right this is great this is kind of
a hack I'm going to redo this in like
three weeks I'm going to come back to it
and revisit it it's entirely likely that
that will get shoved aside in favor of
new feature development and four years
later you'll find a comment to yourself
that says if you're reading this this
function finally broke and you hit that
one race condition
sorry bro
yeah so we we would prefer to avoid that
and we think there are a number of
simple initiatives we can take early on
uh to prevent ourselves from kind of
digging ourselves into an architectural
whole a number of principles for
maintainability
um so we're looking to counteract two
main pain points that both Ryan and I
have dealt with we are former rails devs
and we absolutely love Ruby on Rails
um one thing that Ruby on Rails does
it's not idiomatic to go is it's very
magical which is very convenient however
and go uh it's difficult to build up the
abstractions to support something
magical while keeping type safety and
keeping things what we call maintainable
um so if you have abstractions that make
you wonder what's going on
um that's a terribly good long-term
indicator for a go code base and then
also repeat code at the the application
controller layer uh the problem that we
were running into early on that we took
some steps to to counteract
architecturally so for us maintainable
means
that well maintainable code is easily
extended
which means that you can add new
anticipated functionality so a
maintainable wrapping layer for a web
application for example lets you add web
endpoints with very little overhead it's
not just ordeal of of writing a function
and trying to figure out where to plug
it in to get the route to fire properly
and trying to get all the middlewares
lined up properly the idea is that
maintainable code lets you lets you
extend the functionality in a very
predictable very low overhead manner
maintainable coat is dry you don't
repeat yourself
meaning that if you write a function
that does something like check
authentication on an HTTP request you
shouldn't have to put those 10 20 40
lines of code in every single route that
requires an authentication check you
should be able to abstract that into
middleware which fires every time you
make a request
maintainable code is typesafe static
analysis is for all the obvious reasons
crucial in a go code base which means
that overuse of things like the reflect
package can really not only damage your
performance but just damage your ability
to really know what's going on and
damage your ability to kind of rock at a
glance how your code actually fits
together
um minimal code bottlenecks is another
important thing to keep in mind when
designing a web system so a routes file
is a good example of this if I have a
bunch of developers working on different
features for an API each one working on
a different set of endpoints they all
have to modify a centralized routes file
to add that functionality to the API and
it turns into merge Contract Health Ryan
spent some time working at Facebook and
uh you can speak for for the Facebook
routes file it's a single file of PHP
which is
it's huge I mean when you're first
starting off your Raz file is probably
going to have maybe a dozen
to find it but pretty soon like over
time it grows quickly especially as more
and more people are adding features on
top of your API Facebook's route file
has dozens of merge conflicts a day
and it's a pretty significant problem
that in terms of actually resolving code
I'd say that when I was just building
new features but the amount of time that
I spent resolving browse power complex
yeah more more than it should be right
all you want to do is add a simple
feature you shouldn't have to worry
about accidentally deleting three other
teams features because you're trying to
add yours
um I mean merge conflict resolution
isn't that hard but if it happens often
enough somebody is going to mess up
eventually
um and then also testable code is
important so this means keeping things
modular keeping setting self-contained
avoiding a global config patterns they
can easily Cause Import Cycles
yeah let's talk about the orm
so specifically when we started building
the orm we noticed that there are a few
problems with the RMS that are available
in the go world first it's worth noting
that the orms that exist right now are
into the early stages of development
um which which you know makes makes them
and it makes it understandable that
there wouldn't be a whole lot of
functionality and we thought that that
was a great opportunity for us to be
extremely opinionated about about how we
would go about designing um
to shoot our knees some of the problems
that we found in the RMS that existed
were they weren't typesafe um and that
they were required you to infer a lot
about the models that you're destroying
uh they weren't immediately
comprehensible
um which means that there was a lot of
magic going on uh behind the scenes that
was preventing us from being able to
really understand how different parts of
the era were actually doing their jobs
and the reason why we thought that was
bad was it makes it easy to create new
models but when you decide to do
something fancy then it's really hard to
learn more about how a system functions
and so that's what we mean when we say
it's not easy to build on top of if it's
one thing if it's really easy to add to
10 to 20 new models it's another thing
if you decide that you want to be able
to make a stat in the system so that you
can have
my pre-save hooks or stuff like that and
the orm doesn't immediately support that
and you have to hack it together
a good example of that is
um so some of the orms out there right
now for sleep
will I introspect the model they will
look at the name of the type using the
reflect package they'll store it in a
map
mapping an object of that type to the
name of the the type as a string so if I
have a type called user then that'll get
stored in a map of a an empty user
object to the stringed user and then
that string becomes the table name you
yourself don't Define the tabling by
default there is the option two for many
orms but we consider that slightly
problematic just because it causes a
lack of of transparency causes a lack of
understanding what's really going on
under the hood so later if you want to
write a scraper for example a delayed
job which goes in grabs stuff out of the
database Aggregates it and then sends
you an email report for example you
don't know what the column name is and
it's not terribly easy to find out
without going into the database and
examining the schema rather than an
explicit Declaration of hey we're going
to store this field in the column called
this hey we're going to store it this
model in a table called this without
That explicit declaration we found that
we could figure out what was going on
but it was just a little more effort
than we would like to put in we would
rather put that effort in up front when
we were developing the model then put
that effort in trying to extend the
model later
cool uh so this actually kind of relates
to uh actually who care is familiar with
the web framework martini
awesome uh Martini is a great framework
um the creator of Martini actually put
out a blog post some time back where he
said that although he was very proud of
Martini uh he considered it to be
unidiomatic go because it uses
reflection a lot and because it
obfuscates purposely from the user for
convenience's sake what's actually going
on and then he released a much simpler
package called Negroni which is a great
middleware package this is kind of along
the same lines of that we had the option
to and we certainly could have built a
SQL interaction system using existing
orms but we felt that they were less
idiomatic because they don't let the
user explicitly Define the way in which
the go code is interacting with the SQL
database
so here we're going to show you an
example of how our orm actually
functions the top level of that orm is
actually the model interface and so this
these are the methods that each model
needs to implement in order to provide
the information that the orm needs to be
able to connect and interact with the
SQL database effectively we'll give you
an example of a model so you can see
exactly how this works
great so this is a user model here we
have uh we have some fields on the model
they have Json tags for easy
serialization
and then there are some methods defined
on user which satisfy the interface from
the previous Slide the model interface
so here for example we have a user
returning a string on the method table
and it just says users really
straightforward doesn't change the
string users is the table for all users
all instances of the user type
um below that we have a direct access to
all of the values of the user's fields
at any given point and those are
connected to the names of the columns in
the users table
so instead of guessing which column
which value is going in instead of doing
name manipulation under the hood here it
was our choice just to uh to make it
explicit the relationship between which
column
values are being persisted to and the
value of the persistence
uh so the other two uh methods in this
basic model interface this is kind of a
simplified version of what we're using
um is the insert columns and update
columns these just basically say okay
here are some columns you can insert
into the database and the orm knows what
to make of this
um and then the update columns say okay
here are the columns that you can update
once a model has already been created
the reason that this is important is
because it lets you make certain columns
immutable from the application layer so
if you define a specific slug for like a
blog post for example or like kind of
like Cloud app does a specific short
code you probably want to make that
immutable because it has to do with a
data persistence and just data Integrity
over time
here's a more complicated example
cool so this example is a little bit
more complicated because it uses a
password on a user and it gives you an
example of how you might build on top of
this model to provide additional
functionality so imagine that you had a
user model and you wanted to be able to
take in a plain text password when the
user is created so if you wanted to
attach that password and store the hash
password in the database you wanted to
create a basically a before save book
that automatically hash the password
when the user was created so you didn't
have to do any kind of
hassle when you're actually writing the
creation code
so this describes the password and the
password hash fields on a user struct
then
the only change that you see here in the
update and in the update columns is that
the password hash is added to the update
columns but not the password because we
don't actually want to store the
password field in the database that
would be bad because passwords are
everything yeah there's also a lifecycle
hook right here which basically just
says before you insert the user
um hash the password and persist that
instead so here we could just unmarshul
straight to a user object and then add
the pre-insert lifecycle of a good run
it would hash that couple benefits also
of the uh the models themselves
providing direct access to their fields
means that you can create private fields
on a type and you can make those
accessible to the DB even though you
don't want them accessible to other
packages just another thing that helps
with with maintainability defining a
proper API and only exporting what you
need to export what needs to be
accessible by other packages
uh this is one more example that
provides an additional use case of
extending functionality specifically
this is creating a dependency between
models a way that you might actually use
a dependency between models is let's say
that you have a user model and then you
have a common small and users have many
comments and you you want to tightly
couple the relationship between those
two things such that if you destroy a
user it also goes into the database and
destroys all of that user's comments so
you don't have this digital Comics that
no longer belong to anybody living in
your database so one way that you might
do that with our orm is you might Define
that on the user model
a list of dependencies specifically as
dependents you would say that the common
model maps to a particular join
structure the reason why this is
important is because it allows you to
explicitly Define the relationship
between the user and their comments so
here it says that the feel on the comet
that you care about is called ID and the
field on the user model that you care
about is called or or the field on the
user model's ID in the field on the
comment model that you care about the
user or maybe this allows you to
explicitly Define the relationship
between those two things that's useful
because there are many cases in which
you have multiple possible polymorphic
relationships between different models
for example you might have a user
related to another user as say a
referrer or you might have uh you know
different kinds of relationships between
users and comments and so this would
allow you to explicitly Define the
nature of those dependencies and allow
you to control when uh when those
dependencies cause cascading deletion
awesome here's some example usage of the
Orem
um it's pretty straightforward just
create a user model from the package
models uh with the set fields and then
um very similarly to I mean the the user
interface is pretty similar uh to other
orms out there it's really just under
the hood what's going on that's
significantly different
um so you say error tv.create passing a
pointer to the user
um
it's pretty straightforward stuff
here's the retrieval of a user on the
bottom
one notable departure that you'll notice
from the actual usage syntax so this RM
to something that you might be used to
in a different language like say Ruby or
python is that we're not calling user
dot create or user.update or user.save
or anything like that and the reason why
is because in order to keep the orm dry
and also maintain type safety across
different models you want the actual orm
functions like create get get all things
like that you want those to be top level
functions that accept in a model
where model is the interface that is
implemented by user by comment Etc that
allows you to ensure that you're always
working with a user model or a comment
model and you can keep the code drive at
the same time defining exactly one
create function for the entire orm one
get function for the entire overlay Etc
that's a usage pattern that's pretty
common in going that you won't see in in
other languages so if you're new to go
that's something to pay attention to
yeah yeah uh also completely type safe
as mentioned uh which is just useful if
you have a function on a Model that
returns a different type of object and
you believe you're passing in one type
of object to a database insertion
um
it will catch it statically instead of
waiting for you to find out at runtime
hey you're actually passing in something
which you haven't given instructions to
be in the database
awesome so that's the RM uh second thing
we'd like to touch on is some of the the
middleware compositional stuff we did
um as far as putting routes together for
the web application so uh there are a
lot of middleware solutions out there
that let you define blanket middleware
for a collection of rounds so you can
say things like all right for the entire
application every time an HTTP request
comes in log it to this file right here
you can say things like okay for the
entire slash admin block of Route check
to see if the user has a token in the
header if they do let them through if
they don't 401 however one thing that
was notably lacking is the ability to
compose go code at the route level
instead of the the group of routes level
what this means is every route in a
chunk of routes like let's say slash
users would have to repeat code inside
the controller logic to get set up for
whatever action it needed to perform so
the essence of the post to slash users
route or actually let's say the essence
of the update slash users slash ID route
is to fetch a user from the database
overwrite some values and then write
that user back into the database updated
what that requires is parsing the URL to
turn a user ID into a number and then
using that number to extract the user
out of the database pretty simple stuff
and that's pretty common to other routes
like the delete user slash ID or get
slash user slash ID that code shouldn't
have to be repeated you should be able
to write that once and then let it run
for all of the routes that have an ID
inside the URL however not all of the
user routes have an ID only only a few
of them do post to slash users for
example doesn't have an ID it wouldn't
make sense to say post to slash user
slash ID you've already made a user they
already have an ID
what are you doing so
um
so the the point is that right now uh a
lot of middleware solutions don't let
you define middleware for only specific
routes so you can't drop a blanket
solution that says uh extract the ID
from the URL parse It and Fetch a user
from the database on the whole chunk of
users routes because only some of them
have that ID in the URL in the first
place if you if you say extract this ID
it's going to fail sometimes so we had
this idea of letting ourselves compose
controllers through a combination of
setup middlewares so for a certain
controller we could say Okay extract
this ID fetch from the database and then
proceed only then to the custom logic
which we put inside out inside a
traditional HTTP Handler function
awesome yeah fine grain middleware
yep so we're going to show you a very
brief example of what that looks like
when it's actually implemented so
hopefully you can appreciate the
Simplicity of the solution so just some
overhead that we need to know about are
these types that we've defined
specifically for the notion about route
and the notion of a round collection
so a route has a Handler which defines
what's actually happening when that
route is hit and it also has a slice of
middlewares well middlewares are also
Handler functions that are evaluated in
linear linear order and are composed
within each other that allows you to
basically set up the the Handler that is
actually evaluating they're just being
evaluated at that particular graph a
wrap collection groups a bunch of routes
together and defines middlewares that
should be applied to all of them
this is an example on the type of actors
one the only app is just an example of a
nail aware that you want to use
um
um so here's an example of an actual
route so one thing to note here is that
the actual definition of the route so
the path of the route is defined at the
top inside of the helper function that
we call register all that's doing is
it's saying hey tell the router to be
aware of this particular route
note that the actual path is defined in
the same file as the actual logic that
is being carried out as a result of
hitting that particular route the reason
why we think that this is a good
practice is because it avoids the code
bottleneck that we talked about at the
beginning of the talk where you have one
Central File where all of your workouts
are defined instead your routes are
defined closely coupled with the actual
logic that they're associated with now
you might think that it is valuable for
a developer to be able to see all the
routes in one place and we agree but we
think that that can actually be easily
accomplished by just writing a utility
that goes in and manually Aggregates all
of the route files into one place and
shows you a list of all new routes and
what they do that is preferable to
slowing down development by forcing
people to decouple the actual ground
definition from the logic that's
associated with direct action
yeah this uh
I don't know if this it's a departure
from from a pattern that we've seen in
several open source code bases uh that
basically have one API file that's 1500
lines long uh where people just have a
single map of routes to http Handler
funks and uh we we didn't really like
that approach we feel that this gives us
the ability to work concurrently on
multiple branches of the API at the same
time and make it really seamless to
integrate them less developer overhead
however incrementally
so the end point of the time is that
there are certain steps you can take to
make your code base more maintainable
early on little architectural decisions
that add up over time as far as saving
developers time and effort spent
debugging or resolving merge conflicts
and that's important because in the long
run speed of development really equals
how maintainable your code base is you
can use the reflect package and save
yourself time in setting up a database
you can save yourself time and
development early on but if you if you
put the time in as an investment into
making sure that everything is type safe
everything is readable everything is
explicit it's going to lower the
onboarding cost of bringing on new
developers because they don't have to
hunt more than two or three layers of
abstraction deep to find out what's
going on as far as database interaction
they can find out what's going on at the
route aggregation level pretty easily
because there's no magic going on under
the hood all the files are separate
they're grouped by category they're
grouped by API resource
um
yeah and uh
and just
like in the end if your code is more
maintainable
you're going to find that you spend less
time debugging and more time actually
developing features uh the
infrastructure is an investment
um we'll take questions now in case you
guys have any thoughts or or responses
to some of this stuff in Virginia uh
yeah question in the back so you guys
look into using uh structure tags of the
standard Library does instead of your
column dysfunction
it's
cool it's on the radar
um this was the the initial version like
the other orms uh actually more like the
other orms our our orm is very early on
in development so we have an agenda of
things that we can do to improve it you
notice it's pretty verbose right now
that's something that we're willing to
trade off because we think that making
That explicit is really helpful but
there are certainly other ways to make
it explicit that would cut down line
count so that's a great suggestion yes
yeah I'm ordering in near early design
phase uh if you consider the design that
is more noun verb and less
for you well let's see what I can see if
you have a center of gravity that's
towards the orm Declaration so you can
have a center of gravity that's towards
the database
implementation and there's ways to write
those things sure and I'm wondering if
for your own thinking just your personal
taste and definitely constraints if you
considered more of a noun verb and then
encasing things group that were closer
to the database
encode including in SQL in the name
tonight and rather than you know more
sort of the Rails style or you know more
of the center of gravity towards the
Declaration of New York
that makes sense uh what would an
example of a design pattern that
gravitated towards the database be uh so
just to make sure you properly
understands you can say
you know you have a universe of nouns
and then you start to declare verbs that
are associated with those nouns and The
Logical relationship and code paths that
come from that
um are in the realm of the code but then
at the time they go to get executed is
something that is fairly database
specific and that's all the sort of
interactions instead of having the code
essentially declaratively
close the sequels
right
um
so the truth is we we didn't put a whole
lot of that into that we prefer all at
least I can see for myself I would say I
prefer
um the
the style of orm management that
gravitates more towards the application
Level mostly by Merit of familiarity
um
so that's why we ended up going with
with more of a rail style approach as it
were modified to to fit go idioms
yeah but they're I mean there it's
certainly a spectrum and there's
certainly a way to apply the principles
to writing a database Centric
interaction model
thank you
any other questions yes what's up
yes
foreign
I certainly agree I think they do pull
you in different directions but uh
perhaps I believe I specified actually
for us we were finding the abstract
let's see
in the goals I believe I State
um
we're looking to minimize repeat code
especially at the web controller layer
yeah so that's where we were running
into a lot of problems with uh with
repeating database fetches or
authentication checks for example uh
I mean but as you can see from the orm
we're not averse to putting lines of
code into being explicit about how we
structure our data because that's an
upfront investment that's a fixed cost
as opposed to the variable cost of
um of reading all the controllers which
is probably where we're spending more
development time right now yeah I I
think in the process of system side you
find yourself making making design
decisions that that address trade-offs
exactly like the one that you just
described
abstracting code certainly makes it
easier to keep it dry
um but there's a point I think where it
becomes so abstracted that it's harder
to actually use and build on top of it
and I think the phrase that we like to
use is that it makes you wonder what's
going on and we'd like to avoid that in
order to increase code banking ability
yeah
last couple of months we see many
libraries from GitHub we choose
generation and
our powers
libraries which use just type reflection
for example Json our power startup
library and Json
message Park is positive serializer on
Google Now which use code generation
what do you think about code generation
and writing or else
um so the verbose model right now lends
itself towards code generation in the
sense that we could do kind of if we
really wanted to I suppose we could do
what rails does where it generates a new
file for the model as the boilerplate
has all the methods in the interface
specked out for you and then you just go
in and fill in the columns or whatever
that's assuming we don't
um adopt the excellent suggestion about
the tags on this truck uh
code generation is is certainly useful
especially when you have a schema into
which you can generate things
um
I'm not sure we have specific need of it
right now
with regards to orms I suppose it
depends on how magical the orm is to
so I would say there's an inverse
relationship between how magical an orm
is meaning type inference through
reflection and uh the usefulness that
code generation because if you're you're
explicitly declaring templates or if
you're explicitly writing code that fits
kind of the same mold time and time
again that would make sense that you
would want to kind of automate away the
process of generating that code
but if the orm is picking up everything
for you
um
I would say there's not as much use for
it that's my intuition I haven't done a
lot of thinking on the subject but
um sounds good well thank you all for
your attention uh just to wrap things up
um uh arctos is hiring
and shocking very excited about building
stuff like this or if you're interested
at all here and data science state
analytics uh building a natural language
tool for asking questions about data
then you should absolutely get a ticket
thank you all